plutôt bien pour un jobber
vous avez dit qu'il y aurait un gars pas 5 mais
j'ai dit gardez le jeune homme avec une
moustache en vie pensez-vous que ce gars a l'
air d'âge moyen pas une chance de lui
dire quel âge vous avez euh ça le ferait  fais un
effort d'
accord j'essaie de te sauver la vie
je lui dirai quel âge tu as j'ai 32
ans jésus christ maintenant c'est un
jeune homme avec une moustache non c'est une
barbiche
c'est une moustache et du chaume
c'est  une barbiche qui est une barbiche
qui est une moustache, c'est une barbiche
qui est une ombre a l'air fraîche depuis quand
c'est une poussée de votre grand-père centenaire
regarde que c'est une moustache d'accord
alors qu'en est-il du reste de ces gars hmm
qui tous ces autres gars ici je  je ne
sais pas et ça ne te dérange pas non
parce que j'aime généralement savoir que la
personne que je tue doit être morte
c'est pourquoi tu n'as jamais atteint l'étagère du haut
mon ami bouc ton honneur je
cherche le comptable  Quand est-ce
qu'il rentre à Paris
je jure de le tuer
attends je peux faire venir ce mec  parler tu
ne savais pas que je vais avoir besoin d'une
augmentation significative je veux laisser ma fille plus
que ma pension de merde regarde je
fermerai à 25 ans mais je vais te plafonner à
une demi-douzaine tue une demi-douzaine je '  Je suis
déjà à mi-chemin, on nous a tous
demandé de nous serrer la ceinture, ne le
prenez pas mal, mais vous n'êtes pas mon
temps, je suis le type de tout le monde.